have to pretend that whatever brain fart
whatever brain fart comes out of the
mouth of this 5-year-old toddler yes is
something that we have to take seriously
Bill Maher trying to save liberalism I
dig it this country reminds me of like a
medieval European country where a
five-year-old ascends to the throne and
inherits it and so all the corders have
to pretend that whatever Brave
whatever brain fart comes out of the
mouth of this 5-year-old toddler yes is
something that we have to take seriously
and treat is valid and and debatable
that's what this country is that is very
accurate that was a very incredible
analogy pockets of the country though I
would say Pockets particularly here
right you don't see that stuff in
Tennessee
like yes ma'am no sir you know what I
mean and they don't play around with
that stuff that's what
and that's that's why I completely
understand why people move to places
like Austin and
Nashville